en este vídeo vamos a tratar de
determinar cuál de estas dos gráficas es
la función una función efe de x y cuál
de ellas es su derivada ok entonces
tenemos que determinar quién de ellas es
f x es la gráfica de fx y cuál de ellas
es la gráfica de la derivada de x muy
bien entonces qué pasaría por ejemplo si
la verde fuera la gráfica de fx ok
digamos vamos a vamos a pensar por un
momento que la gráfica de de fs está
verde y vamos a tratar de analizar cómo
es su derivada ok entonces si nos
fijamos aquí en este punto la la
pendiente de la recta tangente que no es
otra cosa más que la derivada es
negativa verdad la digamos la recta va
avanzando hacia abajo entonces eso no
corresponde ni tantito con este hecho de
que la gráfica digamos amarilla o
naranja
es positiva verdad va hacia arriba está
arriba del eje x y además de todo va
creciendo entonces definitivamente no
puede ser la verde la gráfica de la
función f x así que lo que vamos a
proponer ahorita es que la gráfica de fx
es nuestra gráfica amarilla y la gráfica
de la derivada es está verde efe prima
de x muy bien vamos a ver que si
corresponde veamos primero tenemos que
la derivada va creciendo back es
positiva que es positiva y eso
corresponde muy bien que esta la verde
arriba del eje es verdad y de hecho va
creciendo creciendo de hecho perdón al
revés va decreciendo verdad cada vez va
teniendo menos va siendo menos
pronunciada entonces eso quiere decir
que va decreciendo hasta que llega a
este punto máximo en donde la la
pendiente ya es y ya es horizontal y eso
corresponde a que la derivada es 0
verdad y corresponde muy bien en este
punto después de eso la derivada
se hace negativa verdad la pendiente de
la de la recta tangente es negativa
hasta que llega a un punto digamos dónde
es lo más negativa posible en este en
este digamos en este sector y eso
corresponde a este valle verdad después
vuelve a ir creciendo e ir creciendo
hasta que llega nuevamente a un punto
bueno a una colina en donde la derivada
se hace cero y que corresponde muy bien
con este punto ahí corresponde muy bien
con este punto y dijimos que desde aquí
hasta acá y va a ir creciendo la
derivada verdad es decir aquí está muy
pronunciada hacia abajo y después va
perdiendo digamos la inclinación hasta
que termina siendo horizontal y que
corresponde este este punto entonces
hasta este momento la derivada o como
propusimos las gráficas va muy bien
concuerda muy bien con lo que estamos
observando y nada más para terminar
aquí la derivada es positiva verdad
entonces corresponde que ahora estamos
por acá arriba acá la derivada es
positiva es positiva y va creciendo
hasta que llega a un punto máximo de
inclinación verdad y que corresponde a
este lugar y entonces después de eso
cada vez va haciéndome menos positiva es
decir va decreciendo la pendiente y
hasta aquí es en donde nuestro dibujo
llega entonces como propusimos las
gráficas coincide muy bien la amarilla
es la gráfica de la función y la verde
es la gráfica de la derivada porque si
lo pusiéramos al revés no coincide
verdad no coincide porque aquí la
pendiente digamos de la de la de la
gráfica verde es negativa y f es
positiva entonces la respuesta es que la
función es la amarilla y la de luego más
bien la gráfica de la función es la
amarilla y la gráfica de la derivada es
la verde